uh broadcasting live thank you
good evening everyone and welcome to
this annual meeting
of trafford council um
thank you all for attending um sadly um
we haven't
we've been able to schedule it in person
as we would normally like for uh such an
auspicious meeting
um obviously uh with the
each of the municipal years this and the
next one being
extended to 18 months we had hoped that
we would be able to
um but given current circumstances
that's not the case however it is a
very very special day for our incoming
mayor so i'm sure we'd all like to
make it as fitting as we possibly can um
can i just remind everybody that when
you're participating in today's meeting
to please mute your microphone when not
speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chairman that you wish to speak
and please only use the chapman facility
for this purpose
not the price of fish um and can you
please unmute your microphone
when invited um by the chairman to speak
um so with that uh out of the way um
apologies i've received apologies from
councillors dylan
myers and stenit can i ask if there are
any other apologies please
counselor hines mr man
counselor anymore
smashing well with those noted um
we'll uh we shall move on my um
i haven't obviously been um inviting my
chaplain to the zoo meetings however i
did feel that given that this is annual
council
that it would be appropriate to do so um
there are chaplains unavailable so uh
cannon chris ford
who is the area dean of stratford and
the vicaras and mary's davey hume
uh has very kindly uh agreed to lead a
brief reflection
so uh chris would you like to take it
away please thank you mr mayor can i
just check again you can hear me
okay thank you uh i would have
liked to have stayed later for the rest
of the meeting but i have a deanery
synod
where we're discussing reorganization
within the diocese but it has been
emphasized that this
reorganization is not
driven by governance
but by mission and is not
not also the essence of a good
local authority it is not
primarily driven by governments but
by mission and i quote
from the corporate plan
at the heart of our vision is a common
cause
we want to make traffic a better borough
we want to make it a place
where everyone has a chance to succeed
and where everybody has
a voice
how we interpret prioritize
implement and deliver that
vision leads to some
passionate debates in committee
and in the chamber
but ultimately it is a
common cause that best serves the
citizens
of this borough and
this first citizen
councilor rob chilton
has marked his term of oppress as mayor
as a person with that vision
and a very real sense
of mission
his morality like so much has been
limited by this pandemic
but like so many people in the borough
in these times he has risen
to the occasion
we thank him for all he has done
and look forward to council
lawrence walsh's term of office
as new men
now this is just in a moment of
reflection give thanks
for the diversity of talent
within the chamber
and this boron
give thanks for those who serve this
borough
as we continue to face the challenges of
this pandemic
and give thanks that we have learned in
you
to appreciate the good
in one another
lord our god look with love on the
people of this borough
and keep them safe
guide the members of this council and
help them to work together
for the good of the lord
bless their plans and deliberations
and bring them to success
blessed are you lord our god forever and
ever
amen okay
thank you mr mayor thank you chris um
thank you also for your um your kindness
in taking our remembrance service for us
uh recently at trafford town hall which
was very good of you a very short notice
so thank you for being with us this
evening and god speak to your synod
meeting
thanks everybody and i think that would
be an appropriate moment also um
you might be watching later or not to
thank my chaplain uh rev
barbara sharp of saint paul's sale for
her work this year and her support of me
personally
um so thank you to her um moving on
um unfortunately i start the meeting
with some sad news that
two former councillors who served
garbora
have passed away councillor david homer
who was a stratford-borough councillor
mayor of stratford
um trafford represented the longford
ward from 1973
to 80 has passed away um and also
councillor john davenport
who represented the temple award from
1973 to 78
and again from 1984 to 88 has also
passed away
so please could we all pause for a few
moments to reflect and give thanks for
the service of those people
thank you very much the first item of
the business of this meeting
and he sat in the chair already um don't
waste any time
um is the election of the new mayor um
a very uh joyful uh part of this meeting
so uh with that i understand that
councillor acton
will move the motion councillor acton
please thank you mr mayor and can i just
uh before i start can i just add my
thanks
to you uh as the outgoing mayor
for all the work that you've done
through your uh
period of time in office um
yes i i'm absolutely delighted and
honored to be able to nominate my
course hill counselor colleague and
great friend
councilwork lawrence walsh to become the
mayor of trafford
for the next 18 months clearly we are
living in extraordinary times
and extraordinary times does throw up
extraordinary people and we have seen
that here in trafford and across the
country
throughout this pandemic and i know that
in lawrence we're about to elect an
extraordinary person to become
the mayor of trafford i also know that
in rachel he will have a superb mayor s
lawrence and rachel make a great team
and they will bring that teamwork into
their mayoral role and if lawrence
ever gets stuck forward which is highly
unlikely
i have no doubt rachel will be there by
his side
to prompt him i'll try to
just paint a picture of how laurent and
rachel met they met each other
in the local gauss hill co-op where
rachel worked as manager and where
lawrence
shopped you probably could not
meet in a more romantic setting
[Music]
their eyes met across the aisle
by the carrot and swede shelves
and the rest is history as we know
carrot and swede go together
perfectly and i'm sure they both
felt it was a good omen for their
life together a marriage made
in harmony i imagine
seriously they do make a fabulous couple
and they will be bring energy
and commitment to the role of being the
first citizen of trafford
their hearts are rooted in our trafford
communities
and they will definitely bring their own
unique style into their merrell work
we all recognize that in trafford and
across the uk
through this pandemic
people and communities have reached out
to support one another through periods
of lockdown
and restrictions and i know that
lawrence
and rachel will work tirelessly to
support
our communities to get us through to the
end of this
terrible pandemic which hopefully will
not be
uh so long away now with a
with a vaccine uh that's coming along
the trap but we're not there yet and we
need
obviously once we we do overcome this
there will be a transition into what we
hope to be
normality
i know that i've not got long so
you know what while stuck at home during
lockdown
people have tried different things which
they wouldn't ordinarily
do and i'm no different i decided to
play
two different instruments
[Music]
one the ukulele and also
the spoons maybe not the most
classical musical instruments but both
are challenging in their own way
anyway after several months of practice
i've managed to record myself playing
and single
singing a few of the songs
i've learned on my band on my ukulele i
can't call it a banjo
is one brick in the world
and secondly you are my sunshine
i would have liked to have been able to
play live
to you tonight but i think that would
probably
break protocol um you are my sunshine
to lawrence and rachel
but you know i won't be able to do that
i had considered sending the recording
to lawrence and rachel and all
councillors
and to put it on to trafford's youtube
stream
so that the public of trafford could
tune in
however it did occur to me that's not
the best of ideas um
not least because if the conservative
council has heard the recording
they might be motivated to start a
public petition to have me removed from
office for an abuse of power and
offending the good people
of trafford and i have no doubt some of
my labor colleagues would have signed
the petition
too so it's not going to happen tonight
i can promise you
so anyway it just remains for me to say
to lawrence and rachel
have a great term of office and i wish
you all the very best
in your roles as the first citizens of
trafford
and i so move thank you
thank you very much councillor acton um
councillor myers was due to second
emotion
um but he's unable to attend tonight so
i'm sure we would all wish him well
um can i therefore ask councillor anstey
to second the motion on his behalf
well mr mayor and thank you very much
and i i'm afraid i'm not witty enough to
think of it you are my sunshine joke and
tory councillors but i will
get there at some point and by the end
of the meeting i'm sure but um
and and as with council acton um can we
thank you for your mail yeah
all the work you've done over the last
18 months and all the work that we will
do together in the months and years
ahead
uh council myers was indeed very much
looking forward to being able to provide
these remarks this evening so i must
start by
saying to lawrence that if you're happy
with these remarks then i'll take the
credits and if you're not happy with
these remarks then please take them up
with council ohio's directly because um
some of them have been changed but most
of them are what he wanted to say
and about you and so what we've heard is
councillor
lawrence walsh has been a stalwart
member of trafford council and not just
air guys i totally treat
uh for more than 20 years and over that
time has served on health scrutiny
licensing and more recently is the
chairman of the planning
development management committee and
lawrence to everybody who knows is a
local lad
who grew up in old trafford to the sound
of sparrows coughing in the morning
and i'm told that on leaving secondary
school it's rumored that one of the
comments on his report card
read lawrence perseveres when faced with
difficulty
by asking questions he will do well
provided he doesn't go too far um but
there you go right and here you are uh
becoming the first citizen of the brewer
and what an achievement
and recognition i want to have a
passionate interest in education and
that continues um today
and your governor at lost high and was
previously chairman of governors at
grace hill
at primary and for the last 16 years
uh you've enthusiastically represented
the residents of course hill ward
where you're an active member of
volunteer working with the homeless and
with young people
and there's a member of gorgeous
grasshill a group of local residents so
i know
very well from my previous role it
worked exceptionally hard to be able to
improve the local area
and gorgeous schools hill and you've had
great success in improving areas of
waste ground neglected flower beds and
grass verges throughout
your community employed as a postman
with loyal mail at my
offices in norton street in old trafford
a member of the communication workers
union
and a representative within the delivery
office you attend
sands church in stratford and sent here
at lincoln in lost stock
so i think what that says to us is that
traffic is about to happen there
it has public service and commitment
running through
your veins and that i think is fantastic
for the brothers citizen and when time
permits lawrence
his hobbies include listening to music
and watching tv
and we're also told that maybe this is
something you need to take up with
councilman as you enjoy
working out in the gym so that is good
news as well especially in the middle of
a health
pandemic and council acting is referred
to when you met rachel
in the local co-op you married 12 years
ago mitchell has extensive management
experience getting in retail outlets and
restaurants and i know he's looking
forward
to the team that you're both going to be
this year in supporting your chosen
uh charities and so on behalf of the
conservative group
and i have great pleasure in supporting
council lawrence walsh his election
as mayor of trafford for the forthcoming
municipal year
and very best wishes from all of us in
this role thank you mr
thank you very much is the motion
supported by the liberal democrat group
please
it is can everybody hear me just to
start that off
we can thank you councillor brophy yes
so it gives me great pleasure on behalf
of the liberal democrat group to
um support councillor lawrence warsh
he's been an elected counselor for 20
years
an impressive amount of experience and
he's chaired
various committees and what comes across
to me as a long-standing counsellor as
well
is how much he's highly respected across
all parties
and his competence and his fairness and
his reputation there is
is going to stand him well in the role
of mayor
so what comes across about lawrence is
how he's
rooted in his local community he's chair
of governors
for local schools he attended local
schools
and he enjoys volunteering again
completely embedded in his local
community
supporting the projects there working
with young people and the homeless
and so litter pics as well i think
that's such a great thing to do for your
local community
it's there where you meet people and
roll up your sleeves
and get stuck in we've heard about what
he enjoys
that lawrence's chosen charities are
impressive too
we've got gorsh hill studios and the
trafford trussell trust the food banks
now particularly in this covered year
those food banks are much needed and i
know that he's going to be supporting
the food banks across all of the borough
so it gives me great pleasure again to
support
um councillor lawrence walsh to be the
mayor of trafford
thank you very much councillor brophy um
is the
motion supported by the green party
group please
uh yes it is thank you chair um i'm i'm
very pleased to support councillor
walsh's uh very long awaited appointment
as mayor on behalf of the green party uh
lawrence as we've heard has been the
cancer for a remarkable
20 years and which in itself
is a mind-boggling feat for those of us
in the green party
and i know that he's active in many
local groups said gorgeous gorseil has
been mentioned before and
he volunteers to help the community in
in many different ways
and and today's appointment as we've
heard is also good news for the course
hill studios
and the trafford's trussel trust
food banks which are his nominated
charities
uh living locally i know myself how
important the gorsil studios are for the
community and and
the brilliant events they put on and
support they give to local people
and the trusted trust food banks have
sadly come into their own
in this last year or so working harder
than ever and really badly needed
um support at these times so i'm sure
all the money that can be raised for
those two charities will will make a big
difference
i personally most know um lawrence from
my time on the planning committee
which he's chaired for a few years now
and
and from bumping into him in the bike
shed as we lock up our bikes and put on
our waterproofs
so um my request for cancer acton's
serenade would be i like to ride my
bicycle because i know that lawrence is
a keen a keen cyclist
and that i'm not actually requesting you
do it but
um and i know that um from my time on
planning i know
that lawrence is a listener and that
he's someone who really values the
contributions that residents make
uh so i think that is going to be an
important characteristic and i also know
from that time that he really values
fairness and these are going to be
valuable characteristics in his time as
mayor in these unusual times
uh people are going to be struggling and
morale is going to be
low and lawrence and rachel will need to
support our communities as we pick up
the pieces
and try and put our lives back together
i'm sure that they will both do this
admirably and and i wish you both all
the best
in the coming year thank you
thank you very much councillor coggins
so the motion is that council
lawrence walsh b and is hereby elected
mayor of the borough of trafford
for the remainder of the municipal year
and also for the 2021-22 municipal year
so that's 2020-22 all those in favor
please
can i um can i therefore be the first to
offer
um our my congratulations to our new
mayor
councillor walsh may we all give him a
round of applause wherever we are
it doesn't sound as impressive when
we're doing it at home but you get the
idea lawrence
i'm aware that counselor walsh's speech
was uh recorded previously
um and now will be shown as a short
video
so with that i shall take my lever chair
good evening everyone from the sunken
garden
for town hall the first thing i have to
do is thank councillor rob
chilton for all his hard work as mayor
these last 18 months
apart from being the chair of school
governors
chair of sales civic society and others
he's been involved in many organizations
he volunteered to help the distribution
of food parcels
during the lockdown he completed so many
engagements
he may well have set a record
people ask why do we have the morality
answer the main function of the mayor
and maris
is to thank all the volunteers who work
tirelessly
throughout this the year helping others
in the metropolitan borough
of trafford rob has done this so often
himself
he is expertly pleased to thank our
volunteers
he has truly lived up to the title of
first
citizen of the borough and for myself
i have lived and worked in trafford all
my life
to become the mayor of maris is a great
honor for me
and my wife rachel if it is possible to
have an ambition
from our time as mayor romeros it is for
trafford to become a more
caring more tolerant of all its people
father gerald murphy from saint antonio
pardo in stratford
will act as my chaplain and i'm grateful
to him
and the parish for their support
my chosen charities are the trafford
food banks
and ghost hill studios i think not to be
able to feed your family
must be a different devastating
experience
and i applaud all the work the food
banks do to remedy
this it is some years ago that i have
volunteered to work with youth
activities
with young people from old trafford gas
hill studios were willing to help me
with this
and i have had the connection with them
ever since
they continued to go above and beyond
with their support
for young people i hope
everyone can support my fundraising
activities
for these two charities through the next
18 months
there is a great deal of background work
that goes into the office of mayor i
would say
and i have had a chance to see all the
officers in action
since i have been deputy mayor i
continue to be grateful
for all their work and patience which if
it didn't
happen the morality would not be able to
function
a huge thank you to all our officers
and cannot finish we live in strange
times because of the pandemic
but these strange times will not last
forever
we will get through this and i'm sure by
the end of my 18 months
term of office we will have become
stronger and more caring of our fellow
citizens in stratford
thank you everybody everyone and we hope
you have an enjoyable
annual general meeting this evening
thank you
okay good evening everybody and thank
you everyone for your support this
evening
and i wish to announce
that my wife mrs rachel walsh will act
as my mayor s
during my mayoral term
item number two is the appointment of
deputy mayor
the next factor is the appointment of
the deputy mayor councillor chris boyes
and the retiring mayor councillor
chilton will move the motion
as is customary there will be no
speeches at this point
thank you mr um and it gives me um
great pleasure to owe on behalf of the
conservative group
uh to nominate my friend councillor
chris boyes
to serve as deputy mayor for the uh
extended municipal year 2020 to 22.
um and i will reserve any comments for
the future
i notice his wife pam's with us today um
but i very much look forward to that
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor chilton is the
motion seconded
i'll thank that uh mr mayor on behalf of
the labour group
i'm very pleased to nominate councillor
chris boyes uh for the position of
deputy
mayor for the until may uh 2022
he and i have got certain electoral
obstacles to overcome before that
but hopefully we'll be present and and
in person
in uh in may 22 and at least we now have
18 months to find out
this reputable things to say about him
and not just 12 months
so i look forward to may 2022 mr mayor
and i'll and to move chris at that time
thank you councillor brotherton is the
motion supported by the liberal
democrats group
okay that's that's fine everybody um is
the motion supported by the green party
group
uh yes i'm happy to support the motion
on behalf of the green party group to
have um
cancer chris boyes and mrs fanboys as
our mayor and deputy mayor and meredith
thank you councillor coggins and the
motion is that councillor chris boyes
be and is hereby appointed deputy mayor
at the borough of trafford
for the remainder of the municipal year
and also for the 2021-22 municipal year
alba's in favor
thank you everybody may i be the first
you congratulations on your appointment
as a deputy mayor and ask you to appoint
your deputy mayors
councillor boys thank you mr murphy your
congratulations
and i wish to announce that my wife mrs
pamela boys
will act as my deputy mayor s whilst i
serve
as deputy mayor
thank you councillor boys i now call
upon count
councillor holden to move a vote of
thanks to the retiring mayor
and his maris
thank you mr mayor normally
this vote of thanks would be routine
devoted thanks but i think this year
we really should be expressing our
thanks to my colleague rob for his time
his extended time as mayor of trafford
a real vote of thanks for keeping the
civic
part of our borough going for an extra
six months
through the most difficult of times
when meeting people closely uh
communicating with people is so much
more difficult
and i'd also like to thank him
for maintaining the move
from what i refer to as the patrician to
the popular
any of you who have spent any time
in sail town hall will have seen the
pictures and the photographs of past
mayors
flowing gently across the walls and they
look so
solemn and important
when we move to the more modern era
from 1974 onwards within
the town hall that we should be in today
you'll see that although it begins in a
slightly
patrician way gradually but noticeably
humanity takes over and as you move
along that
corridor in the crush wall you can see
people
who quite clearly enjoyed
their time as mayor enjoyed meeting the
people
they were able to meet at the time
and smiled a lot and i'm sure that
you will notice that that's one thing
that rob will be
very good at
exit lines was something i work very
hard on for my farewell speech
i'm going to leave those to rob i won't
steal any more of the
possible lines but i would like to
just highlight one phrase
in my very limited latin omnis
pelvis omnim
in porvus and i'll tell you what that
means in a few moments
i know you'll miss being the mayor we
all do
but there really is life after the
minerality
and remember omnes
enim porvus the phrase that was
whispered
into the departing ear of roman
generals after major campaigns
by one of their slaves and it translates
as all
is dust
having done your job having filled the
role
everything in the future will be dust
the romans got a lot of things right but
they were wrong
in this case you have a long
period of life and i'll warn you
that you will go through it meeting
people in the street who will say to you
didn't you used to be the mayor and get
used to that because it's great
it really is thank you rob
thank you for your 18 months of service
thank you for your cheerfulness thanks
for your dedication
and we love i look forward to welcoming
you back in the ward because there's a
big backlog that we've left for you
thank you and well done
thank you councillor holden
the vote of thanks is to be seconded by
the leader of the council
thank you mr mayor and on behalf of your
colleagues in the labor group can i be
one of the first to congratulate both
yourself and rachel
um on the roles that you take up tonight
we're incredibly proud of you and know
you'll do
a fantastic job for the people of
trafford
and i was told not long after my
election
to this council that all mayors bring
something of their own personality
to the role which i know caused
significant trepidation amongst many of
others last year
when rob chilton became the mayor
of trafford and whilst um
many members were concerned about
what may unfold following his accession
to the
morality um none of us were nearly as
concerned as
many council officers who i am told were
incredibly worried
about how this surly shirty fussy
individual
would go as our first citizen and it
wasn't long
mr mayor and maybe three or four weeks
into
the role before there were whispers in
the corridor
um where my office is located amongst
officers that something very strange had
happened
to our mayor that he seemed to be
walking about the place an awful lot
smiling and being incredibly happy
something that they'd not seen
in his near 10 years of service
but that was very much a result they
felt
of how happy he was to be taking on um
this role and he's done an incredible
job many people tonight have already
referenced the very difficult and
challenging times
that we live in but actually you know
rob has come into this role with a very
specific set of views and values
somebody keen to uphold our traditions
and our heritage and he's done that
in a number of different ways from the
way in which he has
involved our recently appointed alderman
particularly council for mrs ward
in events as he's gone through and in a
number of
ways in which he's undertaken his duties
um but more than that he's shown an
incredible amount of
compassion as he's done about his work
and that's something that's particularly
been seen
over the past nine months not everybody
would have been able to accept
their an extension willingly or as
willingly as rob has to the term of now
it's an incredibly
draining role even when there um are
necessarily less visits than usual but
he has continued
in that spirit attending those events
that he can
making sure that residents at for
instance remembrance events have been
able to
see the mayor to see our first citizens
setting a good example
um for our community and doing a
fantastic job but he's also
been as others have referenced on the
front line himself he and i
um did a great number of shifts at sail
west
um early on in the pandemic and whilst i
had to step back from that i know that
councillor chilton continued to be
heavily involved in that
alongside his mayoral duties and
they are duties that he's taken very
seriously as i said
mr mayor he's only occasionally been
brought into line by his mayoral
attendants tony and matt normally for
trying to
sneak a cigarette while still wearing
the chains um
but thankfully i think we managed to
avoid that particular hiccup even in
um car park around the back of sail town
center which was the occasion i
witnessed him
getting closest to doing so um but he
was
prior to the pandemic bringing um
you know significant rigor to the role
i'd see him one night at an awards day
at an awards evening the next day we'd
be in a furniture showroom being shown
around and he
whatever the event was he
went about it with typical good grace
and represented us
fantastically well as all of our mayors
do and he's added to
um the great lineage and tradition that
we expect of anybody who takes
um on that role but i do just want to
say
um that in spite of everything that has
gone on
this year he has also raised a
phenomenal amount for charity and i
think we'll hear
um a little bit about that fairly soon
but i think i'm correct in saying that
he's raised almost 40
000 pounds through the mayoral charities
um for
for those causes about which he is
incredibly passionate and i think that
in these particularly challenging times
we should recognize
that work as well i do also want to say
very briefly
mr mayor a word of thanks on behalf of
all councillors for rob's two mareses
zoe who unfortunately due to ill health
was not able to
continue um throughout the year as mayor
s
and then more recently tilly who stepped
into the breach and both have done
a fantastic job supporting rob and
acting as
um mares across um the borough but
ultimately mr mayor there are only a
handful of things that we ask for from
our mayors to be an ambassador for the
borough
to be fair-minded and to be a force for
good and i i
sincerely second this on the basis that
rob has
undoubtedly met all three of those
criteria he's been a fantastic
first citizen he'll be a hard act to
follow and i'm sure all of us
thank him very much for the work he's
done and know that
whilst he um you know is finishing as
mayor
he's got some um fuel left in the tank
to continue as a local councillor for
now
and that whatever he does in the future
from what we've seen over the past 18
months he'll continue to be a force for
good
in his community thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor weston is the vote
supported by the
liberal democrats group
it is um mr mayor so firstly
i'd just like to offer my
congratulations to to lawrence for
becoming our mayor i'm sure you'll do a
great job and looking forward to the
meetings and we can all be back in the
town hall
but moving on to rob last time
18 months ago i think it was when i was
asked to support
um rob chilton and his role of mayor
we took it upon ourselves to make meet
for coffee around trafford
and then we ended up sharing a train
journey on behalf of the
council because there was a health
scrutiny meeting we were
attending and i have to say in knowing
rob
he has been a truly magnificent mayor
for trafford
and we've all benefited from his
hard-working service his humbleness
and his absolute dedication to this
important job
i know it's been a wonderful year for
rob and he's told me
how on the phone just how much he's
enjoyed it
particular high spots i've heard are the
drivers
tony and matt who have assisted him on
on the roll
and tidied him up where where needed and
for rob his he's working towards the
ministry and the church and i know how
comfortable he is with that role
compared to being a counselor but as
mayor i know you've worked hard rob on
the community
cohesion that you wanted to promote in
your role of mayor
and i know as part of that you've
visited
synagogues mosques hindu
areas of worship as well as churches and
i think as a result of that embeddedness
in the community and that commitment to
trafford
as um we were just saying before the
amount of money you've raised for those
charities is truly impressive
and i know you've had some high spots
it's been a difficult year
um some of it the last six months has
been under under lockdown
and the covered restrictions but there's
a couple of examples that you shared
with me that i just wanted to let other
councillors know
there was one mayoral duty that rob had
to do
which was a doggy day care opening
and apparently knowing how much rob
loves dogs
how difficult it was for the staff to
get him to leave
that doggy daycare center and when he
was involved in
in launching that another high spot i
know
how committed rob has been to um
visiting all the care homes in trafford
and we
we all know how difficult and how
challenging the situation has been for
our care homes but rob managed to
visit most of them even during lockdown
i'm told he
managed to appear on a zoom camera at
the sunrise
care home in hale barnes so all the
residents there were able to see him
beamed in
through their tsp screens so finally
it gives me great pleasure to just um
give a true thank you to rob chilton
who's been a magnificent mayor
and for his mayor asses too thank you
thank you councillor brophy is the vote
supported by the green party group
it is chair um when i spoke to wish
councillor chilton and his mares as well
for the mayoral year 18 months ago i
think none of us expected what was to
come
and and an 18 month year was probably
the first of many surprises for a team
that had uh signed up for the more
traditional 12-month year
but i think you'd probably expected to
meet
more people than you'd ever done before
in your life to shake more hands than
you had ever shaken before
but sadly for a lot of your term that
wasn't possible
and but the work of a mayor and my rest
was needed actually more than ever
and i know that you have really filled
that role in a remarkable way
under remarkable circumstances uh
presumably you didn't expect to
spend your days working from the sail
west hub helping trafford residents
whose lives had
been turned upside down but that is how
you chose to spend your time and and we
really appreciate that
uh i know that rob and zoe and and
lashley tilly have worked tirelessly for
the community this year
which is not surprising because actually
they had worked tirelessly for the
community before that as we noted last
year when we
when we welcome to them so really this
is just a continuation
of um a dedicated pattern of public
service
uh we know as well that charities across
the country have taken a real hit this
year with fundraising events cancelled
and donations um suffering due to job
losses and uncertainty
and yet despite this you've managed to
raise a phenomenal amount of money for
for the alex hume foundation for the
friends of manchester hospitals
and the society for abandoned animals uh
you nominated charities so that really
is a remarkable
uh achievement and i can i also take a
minute to thank the mayoral assistants
tony and matt who we see
um at council meetings and uh all sorts
of
uh interesting and unusual events across
the year and i know that their work is
appreciated very much by the
the mayors and deputy mayors and mareses
and and also by the rest of us
so i think i can say with confidence
that rob and your marissa's
have had a year that you you will not
forget and we want to thank you
on behalf of the green party for all
your work
thank you councillor coggins when
the motion is that the council hereby
place on record their appreciation
for the manner in which council shilton
has carried out his duties as mayor of
the borough of trafford
during his period of office and send it
to him their best thanks
in that connection they also express
their gratitude to ms zoe marshall
for the manner in which she has acted as
his maerus
and to mrs tilly rothwell and his other
friends and family
for the moment in which they have
supported him and acted as
as his consort from time to time all
those in favor
aye aye thank you everybody
i now call upon the retiring mayor
councillor chilton
to respond
well thank you very much mr mayor and
may i thank
all the speakers for their comments uh
very good friends all i have to confess
i wasn't i didn't quite recognize the
person they were talking about on
occasion but um
i i really do appreciate those very kind
words
and mr mayor i very much enjoyed working
with you and rachel as deputy mayor and
deputy mayor s
you've both been extremely helpful and i
think we made a good team
for the past municipal year or 18 months
uh you'll be a great mayor and i look
forward very much to supporting you
in your term of office um i've also been
very fortunate to have a fantastic uh
chain gang as we're called of greater
manchester mayors
to work with um the nine other people
you get thrown together with
um from across greater manchester can be
a bit of a lottery
but we all really hit it off this year
and we'll all stay in touch
long after our terms have ended so that
is uh that's that's been lovely
i've also been similarly fortunate to
have two amazing greater manchester high
sheriffs to work with
mark adelston and eamon o'neill both of
them trafford residents
and so arbor has been well and truly put
on the map during their tenure
and i'd like to thank them for their
tremendous service and the support
they've afforded me personally
from the outset i i wanted to make
community cohesion a theme of my year
in office and i've been so delighted to
visit many of trafford's different
communities
and indeed represented our borough at
community gatherings across the wider
county
i'm also really pleased that with my
friend josh fulcher
we were able to relaunch the community
cohesion forum
and do our little bit to build links and
start conversations
and similarly i'm pleased that before
covid i was able to realize my ambition
of visiting as many of trafford's care
homes as possible
it's very humbling to chat to so many
people who have seen so much change over
the years
and i hope my visits made the staff and
the residents at our fantastic homes
across the borough feel valued
and while some perhaps not as convincing
with young people as some of my
predecessors were
i'm still pleased that we've been able
to sustain the important primary school
visits to the town hall
our partnership with trafford college of
course and a strong relationship
with the scout and guide organizations
across the borough
i'd like to thank natalie and michelle
and ian and all the democratic services
officers for their hard work
and for putting up with me this year
which is never an easy task
um i'd like to thank jane lefevre also
for giving me
the all the advice council meetings
which i i often listen to
um and i particularly like to thank the
two people i work
closest with throughout the municipal
year uh tony lock and matt madeley the
attendants
we've got quite a similar sense of humor
and we've had a great laugh over the
year
we've put the world to rights between us
they're both an asset to the borough and
i will miss them both very much indeed
and i'd also like to thank all
councillors for their cooperation at
full council meetings
especially in difficult circumstances of
late where we've had to do them over
zoom
um i do appreciate i've been a bit of a
grumpy guts as chairman but
you knew what you were getting so there
you go um
to say my term hasn't exactly been
played plain sailing
is a bit of an understatement um but
it's an enormous privilege to serve as
trafford's first citizen
i can't complain i've had 10 months
which is more than most people get
and it's been wonderful um 10 months
that is of a
normal year and then of course we went
into lockdown and i still had things to
do then of course
it's a role that brings with it great
responsibility but also a great deal of
satisfaction
to some people i suppose um the
mayoralty might seem a bit of an
anachronism
um but this really is fundamentally
misunderstanding what it's about
and there's actually hardly any of this
dickensian image of
sitting at dinners in robes filling your
face as as popular myth would have it
sorry to disappoint you lawrence um but
indeed i'd probably pass the test they
perform in high wycombe
of weighing their mare annually to see
if he's put on weight
um although actually i did have one too
many fray bentos during the lockdown so
i might not know actually
um but in a fast-moving era that we live
in where so much is falling by the
wayside
the general public really do value the
tradition and pageantry
associated with a role that's that is
hundreds of years old
dating backers as it does to the town
pro trees of norman times
the mayoralty and i must warn you this
lawrence is actually quite an intense
schedule
uh for what's technically not a
full-time job you can have anything up
to three or four engagements in a day
during busy periods
you have to be on time dressed smartly
and you have to be at your best to
portray a good image of the borough
um obviously when i've occasionally come
out of the house looking like a sack of
potatoes
tony has been on hand to smarten me up
to some tune
i might add um there are really
um four strands to the mayoralty
the council role the ambassadorial role
the community role and the charity role
and it's important for all four really
that the person selected
um is a non-political unity figure
at least for their year of office and
that's why the role to me is so crucial
uh so to take them in turn the council
role is obvious you cheerful counsel and
preside over major events
during my year it's been an enormous
honor to represent the borough at the
services of remembrance
as well as events to mark the
anniversaries of d-day and the battle of
britain
the civic service in 2019 was a great
day which really showcased the community
in sale
but had representatives from many
different parts of the borough
and different faith communities the
civic reception in january this year so
showcased our sail waterside to the
wider community
and the other mayors um and i know of
course
sail waterside was something that our
late colleague councillor jane bohr
very much appreciated and and i hope
will have
will have remarked upon and similarly in
january it was a very sad but huge
privilege
to preside at the civic funeral of our
friend councillor ray bowker
a predecessor of mine who gave so much
of his life
to serving this borough and that really
was an honor
uh secondly the ambassadorial role is in
itself pretty crucial
um from consular receptions to community
events across the wider county
this there are too many such events to
expect an exec member or an officer to
attend
so having the mayor available for these
is a dignified way
of ensuring that the flag is flown for
trafford across greater manchester and
indeed sometimes across the world uh
these have been an eye-opener i have to
say and
i've been so pleased to meet so many
different people from different
countries
faiths and walks of life during my term
the community role thirdly is similarly
important and
allows the council to visibly support
all kinds of events across the borough
from business openings to charity coffee
mornings
from choir concerts to major church
services
and this again ensures that the
fantastic work that is being undertaken
by residents and businesses across
trafford
whether to support our economy or
entirely on a voluntary basis
is recognized and applauded by the local
authority
and again there are far too many of
these from even to enumerate let alone
to expect a political leader to attend
them all instead
and finally and fourthly there's the
charity role and the mayoralty is a
unique opportunity as you will find
uh mr mayor to raise funds for good
causes locally
i particularly like to thank my
wonderful charity committee for their
help this year
they've been absolutely amazing and
together we've been able to raise 38
291 pounds and tuppence for my three
charities
the alex hume foundation manchester
hospital's foundation trust charity
and the society for abandoned animals
and i was particularly pleased about the
toppings for some reason
and obviously at this difficult time for
charities in the uk
i hope that this sum will make a
difference
i'd also like to thank all the people
who've accompanied me to engagements to
make sure
i don't have my shirt hanging out or
have a face on
um to my mum and my nan to zoe
tilly marge barbara julie christine
linda lynn k laura sean
judith and of course alderman viv thank
you all so much
so i'd like to use the next 40 minutes
of my speech so
no i'm just kidding i'd like to conclude
my speech in acknowledging
the importance of the role to the
borough by asking everyone
to please support our fantastic new
mayor lawrence walsh
and his wife rachel i know that they
will find the challenging aspects of the
role a lot more manageable
with the support of the council and
everyone at this meeting today
so please everyone do whatever you can
to support him
and encourage him as he sets about the
difficult task of promoting and engaging
with our borough
as we emerge from a crisis that's
engulfed every aspect of our lives
and finally i would like to take this
opportunity to thank everyone who has
worked so hard
to keep our borough running during covet
19
from key workers and emergency service
personnel to our council staff and
resident volunteers
you are all wonderful and god bless you
all thank you very much
thank you councillor chilton we will now
turn to the business part of the meeting
and now i mentioned that should have all
be required you will then use the
polling option
in zoom at the appropriate time i will
now
announce that i am putting the matter to
the vote
i remind you that a window will appear
on your screen
and you'll be asked to click on one of
the three options available
for against abstain once you have
selected your preferences
please click submit at the bottom of the
window and the outcome of the vote will
appear on the screen
once all votes are in
we'll go to item number four i move that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
30th
of september 2020 up to be taken as a
read
as a signed record correct record
all those in favor aye
all right we officially need a second
after that
like sucking those minutes second good
mr man
thank you councillor weston and before i
go to the next item item five i
understand council western
wishes to make an announcement
councillor weston i did
mr mayor and forgive me because it is
quite an unusual announcement
but um you know an occasion such as this
i um i did want to take the opportunity
to
inform all members and she doesn't know
that i'm going to do this the council of
duffield will be
um stepping down from council um on the
30th
of november due to work commitments as i
think many of you know
and was planning to step down in may
just gone
um and i think had hoped to stay through
to the
following may but unfortunately um due
to those commitments isn't able to do so
and um is obviously a former
mares of the borough so in many ways an
annual meeting such as this
um is a timely opportunity to
um wish her farewell and all the best
for the future she's also a former chair
of licensing
member of numerous committees and
members of the shadow executive and i
just wanted to take the opportunity
um mr mayor as we're all together
tonight and we know that that
is coming in a few days to place on
record my thanks to am we were elected
on the same day back in 2011 nine and a
half years ago
now she's very proud of telling me that
she has not only a bigger
majority than me but i think um the
highest number of votes ever recorded
for anybody
in trafford in a local election ever um
so i'm sure all colleagues will wish um
to join me in uh thanking emperor
service to the people of trafford and
wishing her all the very best for the
future
thank you mr mayor and apologies for
that rather unusual announcement
thank you councillor weston item number
five
the council is requested to note the
continuation of the leader of the
council's term of office
until the expiry of his term of office
as a councillor
in 2003. i invite the leader of the
council
andrew weston to appoint his deputy and
members of his executive
thank you mr mayor as per the report
i appoint councillor catherine hines as
deputy leader of the council and the
members of the executive as listed thank
you mr mayor
thank you councillor weston item number
six the council is asked to note the
membership of the shadow executive
is that noted
[Music]
thank you everybody item number seven
council matters
and i invite the leader of the council
to move the recommendations
for the proposed committee structure for
the remainder of the 2020-21
municipal year thank you mr mayor the
report is self-explanatory so i won't go
into detail but i would just like to
draw members attention to recommendation
five because that's been
an unusual past nine months but i'm sure
members
will welcome the proposed return to more
usual
committee structures and also timings
and with the stepping back up with our
scrutiny committees and the return
to um evening meetings where committees
traditionally
meet in the evenings from um january
2021
and with that i'll move the report thank
you mr matt
is that seconded seconded mr mayor
thank you um any members wishing to
speak to this item
okay um is that agreed
i agree thank you item number eight
outside bodies
as an update to the outside body
nominations circulated with the report
please note that council of whittem is
the nomination for the greater
manchester police and crime
steering group and councillor freeman
his deputy
also please note that councillor karina
carter
is nominated for the corporate issues
and reform
gmca scrutiny committee and as
substitute on the greater manchester
health
scrutiny committee on the executive
outside bodies list
councillor graham whittam is on the
assets and community value panel
in place of councillor white
with those updates i move the report can
i have a second to please
thank you councillor weston
item number nine meetings timetable
i apologies everybody we need to do that
for me all in favor
aye aye aye aye aye
action number nine meetings timetable
the council is asked to reconfirm the
timetable of meetings agreed by council
on the 30th of september 2020
for the remainder of the 2020 21
municipal year
with the addition of an annual meeting
on the 26th of may
2021 at 6 pm
all the council is asked to know that
from the first of january 2021
it is proposed that all meetings will
commence as out
as in the constitution do i have
council's consent
delegation and urgent action please
could council approve the committee
arrangements for dealing with delegated
decisions
and urgent action i set out on the
council summons
is that agreed
hi item number 11 delegation of
functions
and amendments to the constitution
council is
asked to confirm the arrangements for
the delegation of council
and executive functions council has also
requested to agree constitutional
changes
in response to the local government
ethical standards areas
of best practice which has been
presented to and agreed by standards
committee
first of all the updated executive
portfolios and office scheme of
delegation are set out in the papers
and i invite the leader of the council
to move this item
thank you i'm just going to pause
briefly everybody just
have a little pause
[Music]
thank you everybody for your patience
any council's wishing to speak to this
item
okay turning into the report on
the response to the local government
ethical standards areas
of best practice may i
number 11 delegation of functions and
amendments to the constitution
thank you we want to get it absolutely
perfect this evening
and so i'm going to turn into the report
the motion's been moved and seconded
thank you should anyone wish to speak
to this item
okay turning to the report on the
response to local government ethical
standards areas
of best practice may i invite the
executive member for finance
and governance to introduce this item
counselor ross thank you very much mr
mayor and first of all can i place on
the
record my congratulations to you and to
your mayor s rachel
and i hope you have a wonderful 18
months ahead i know that you're going to
make a smashing job
as mayor and there s for the borough
moving on to this report
the committee and standards in public
life completed an in-depth review of
ethical standards within local
authorities and published its report in
2019 recommending 15
areas of best practice the standards
committee considered this
original report and were advised that
trafford already met a number of these
areas of best practice an action plan
laying out how the council met or would
meet
all 15 best practice by june 2020
was agreed by the committee in january
2020
in order to meet the outstanding
recommendations changes are required to
the council's constitution
the proposed amendments were considered
by and approved by the standard
committee in march this year with the
intention that they would have been
recommended to council for adoption
at the annual meeting which was
originally scheduled for may 2020
the changes recommended would amend the
code of conduct for members as set out
in appendix one
to include the following a prohibition
of bullying and harassment by members
a requirement that members comply with
any formal standards investigations
and a prohibition of trivial or
malicious allegations by members
other recommendations which the council
is recommended to agree are
that the code of conduct conduct is
regularly reviewed and this is now
proposed to be carried out in 2021
the adoption of a public interest test
is set out in appendix 2
and a requirement to publish a decision
notice on the conclusion of a formal
investigation
as an appendix 3. the council is
accordingly being
asked to agree the amendments to the
council's code of conduct and complaints
procedure
within the constitution and to adopt the
decision notice and two-stage public
interest test
for complaints against members to
trafford council as set out in the
report thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor ross is that a
second it
i can do it mr mayor thank you
councillor weston the motion has been
moved and seconded is it agreed
[Music]
item number 12 is executive decisions
special urgency
the final report this evening details
the executive key decisions which have
been taken
under the special urgency provisions and
is for the council to note
can that therefore be noted
hi
[Music]
thank you everybody and this then brings
us to the end of the meeting
i'm sure you will agree that has been a
little different this year
but hopefully we may now start to see an
improvement in the situation
and if things can get a little bit more
back to normal we may look forward to a
more traditional
annual meeting next may thank you
everybody
and please keep safe
thank you thank you
thank you congratulations